[Music]
all right we have big breaking
developments tonight on our equal our
quest for equal justice and to hold
those that have abused power accountable
let me give you a headline there's a lot
of news coming this week that I know of
so stay tuned
but according to just release reports
Judicial Watch a federal court now has
ordered a hearing about whether to speed
up the release of key struck page text
documents and the American Center for
Law and Justice has now obtained the
Obama do J's immunity agreements with
Hillary Clinton lawyers Cheryl Mills
Heather Samuelson to quote now pay
attention I'm not making this up to
dispose of evidence and refuse to comply
with federal law I'm sure they do that
for Donald Trump too now this all comes
as sources are telling Fox News Tonight
the John Durham he is the prosecutor
from Massachusetts that he is zeroing in
on why certain pieces of exculpatory
material may have been withheld from the
FISA Court as it pertains to spying on
the team of Trump here now with more
reaction author of the next read wave a
el aclj executive director Jordan
Sekulow along with Judicial Watch
president tom Fitton let's start with
hang on a second I've never heard except
for struck and page destroying their
phones which Muller did I've never heard
of the attorneys for Hillary Clinton in
a case where we know the evidence is
overwhelming she had these emails Jordan
and we know know that she also deleted
the subpoenaed emails and all that's
then the bleach pit I never heard of
allowing the destruction of evidence and
those two lawyers sat in when she was
being interrogated by the FBI either if
you ever hear that before cuz I have in
Jordan no I mean first they were aides
to Hillary Clinton Cheryl Mills was her
chief of staff when she was Secretary of
State and Heather Samuelson was her
senior advisor and White House liaison
for the Secretary of State in the State
Department then when Hillary Clinton
leaves the Secretary of State position
they become her private attorneys they
take over these emails they're called
culling computers each one had one
these were the backups to the infamous
server out in Colorado that had the
sixty-two thousand emails on them each
had it and guess what each was going
through as now Hillary Clinton's lawyers
and deleting emails Sean so when this
investigation began they wanted to make
sure right off the bat they were immune
from the Espionage Act the Records Act
the classified information Act
I mean crimes that bring prison time of
up to twenty eight years if you can buy
them for each of these actors and yet
they get full immunity but not just that
as you said they also get the DOJ and
FBI to agree to not allow the American
people to access this information on
their computers via FOIA and we've got
that document right here and then
they'll destroy the computers for Cheryl
Mills and Heather Samuelson and the
Clinton team obviously that would never
happen for Team Trump let me go to tom
Fitton Tom Judicial Watch the hearings
about whether to speed up the struck
page document release now we have a lot
of the text messages but they keep
dribbling out more and more and you keep
getting them how much more do we think
is out there oh there's thirteen
thousand more pages and the FBI is
taking the position that they generally
shouldn't have to turn over any text
messages so we don't know what text
messages are being withheld and the
court has looked at the production
schedule there's been twenty thousand
records generally over the last year
year and a half they've only produced or
processed a 500 per month about six
thousand so he's looking seeing thirteen
thousand records still to be produced he
wants to have a court here and you take
another look to see whether or not this
is quick enough
I hope thank you he forces the release
of these records quickly thank you both
this is important work to do